en el último vídeo teníamos una matriz a
y esta matriz era una matriz de n por n
que empezamos por aquí tenemos la
entrada a 1 1 seguía la entrada a 1 2
hasta la entrada a 1 n
y después nos seguíamos poniendo todas
las filas hasta que llegábamos a una
fila muy particular la décima fila ok la
cual tiene entrada a y uno después a dos
y así hasta la entrada a i n y seguimos
poniendo las pilas hasta llegar a la
enésima fila con entrada a n1 y n2 a nm
y bueno de esta matriz queríamos sacar
el determinante y bueno en algún punto
del vídeo queríamos sacar el
determinante de esta matriz y lo que
hacíamos era escoger una de sus filas
de hecho la fila que escogimos era esta
fila y entonces el determinante vea
determinante de a era igual a pues
acabamos el signo y para tomar el signo
de la primera entrada lo que tenemos es
menos 1 elevado a y más 1 que son las
coordenadas de la primera entrada porque
están en la décima fila y primera
columna entonces esto de aquí es el
signo de la entrada multiplicamos por el
valor de la entrada que es aa1 y después
multiplicamos por el determinante de la
sub matriz hay uno que es lo que nos
queda de eliminar la décima fila y la
primera columna ok esto también lo
pudimos haber escrito como
el determinante de la su matriz
y uno y después sumamos el segundo
término que lo que hace es tomar la
segunda entrada que la segunda entrada a
2 multiplicamos por el signo de la
segunda entrada de esta fila aunque es
menos 1 elevado a la potencia el número
de file más el número de columna ok y
después multiplicamos por el
determinante de la sub matriz ai2 ok y
así hacíamos un montón de términos uno
para cada una de las entradas de la íes
y más fila o sea uno para cada columna
de la matriz hasta que llegábamos a la
enésima columna ok entonces tenemos que
menos 1 a la y más n por a y n por el
determinante de a y n bueno resulta que
un error muy común es olvidarse de poner
este
y un montón de personas en lugar de
poner el determinante de la sub matriz
hay uno
y de la sub matriz hay dos y todas esas
matrices
lo que hacen es poner tal cual a la
matriz ayuno y a la matriz hay dos y hay
tres y hay cuatro pero eso no está bien
porque aquí lo que tenemos de este lado
el determinante de a se supone que es un
número fijo y de este lado lo que
tenemos ya no es un determinante de una
matriz más chica que la matriz a sino
que es tal cual una matriz aunque sea
más chica que a es una matriz no es un
número entonces de este lado lo que
tenemos es una matriz una matriz
y de este lado lo que tenemos es un
número fijo un número y además es una
matriz de n
1 por n menos 1 y ninguna matriz de n
1 por ende menos uno puede ser igual a
un número a menos de que sea una matriz
de uno por uno
ok entonces hay que tener muchísimo
cuidado en que no se nos olvide poner
por aquí que este es el determinante de
la sub matriz hay uno ok que también se
puede poner así
vamos a dejarlo con una misma anotación
entonces aquí va el determinante de 2 y
determinante de a&m